SPEAKER: I'm pleased to be
here today for a Talk at Google
with Mr. Robin Hanson.
Robin is a research
associate at the Future
of Humanity Institute
at Oxford University,
an associate professor of
economics at George Mason
University.
He's known for his ideas on
idea futures and markets,
and was involved in the creation
of DARPA's Future Map project
in the Foresight Institute's
Foresight Exchange.
He invented market scoring
rules, like the LMSR,
used by prediction markets
such as Consensus Point, where
he is the chief scientist,
and has conducted research
on signaling.
Hanson's blog,
"Overcoming Bias,"
has more than 50,000
visitors per month,
with more than eight
million views since 2005.
Robin, thanks so much for
joining us, and welcome.
ROBIN HANSON: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I plan to leave lots
of time for questions,
but feel free to ask
questions along the way.
And I'll feel free to say later.
[LAUGHTER]
Deal?
All right.
This is a big picture.
This is the US economy
over the last four years.
A few days ago, that
last bar came out.
It's always big news--
the economy bumps
up or down a little bit.
But we're going to be talking
about a bigger picture.
This is the world economy over
the last half century or so.
And now on the y-axis,
it's a logarithm
of the size of
the world economy.
And as you know, logarithms make
exponentials look like lines.
And that's roughly a line.
So the major news over the
last half century or so
is the world economy's
been slowly doubling
roughly every 15 years.
But if you go back even
farther-- say, 2,000 years--
it's still a log axis.
But it's no longer a
line because it was not
exponential growth.
There was the famous
Industrial Revolution.
Before that, it looks
like there wasn't growth.
And then we've been growing
like gangbusters ever since.
But if you look back even
farther, over 10,000 years,
you'll see that there
was a farming revolution
7,000 years or so ago.
And it was growing
exponential after that.
During the farming era, it was
doubling roughly every 1,000
years.
And before then, it looks like
it was growing even slower.
But of course, it was, in fact,
growing exponentially, roughly.
It was growing even slower.
And if you go back
even farther, you'll
see that brains
were growing roughly
exponentially over the
last half billion years.
And even farther
back, genome seems
to have been growing
exponentially
over many billions of years.
If you just look at the last
period of human history,
you'll see that this
sequence of growth
is fit pretty well by just a
sequence of exponential modes,
i.e., exponential growth
with sudden transitions
to faster growth modes.
So if we put this
all on one graph,
now it's again
logarithm, but now it's
logarithm of the growth rate.
And on the y-axis,
now I've changed
it to be a logarithm
of time until sometime
in the near future so I
can fit this all on here.
And so then you have
very slowly growing
things like animal
brains, humans growing--
doubling roughly every
quarter million years--
farmers doubling
roughly every 1,000,
industry doubling
roughly every 15,000.
If this trend were
to continue, then
the statistics of the last
few modes suggest roughly
there would be a transition
some time roughly
in the next century or
so-- not very precise.
Within a five-year
period, the economy
would go from doubling
every 15 years,
like it does now, to doubling
every month or faster.
And then that would
last for a year or two.
And then something
else would happen.
What could possibly
cause such a thing?
One of the most
common speculations
about a really big disruptive
change on the horizon that
could change everything
is smart robots--
artificial intelligence.
And there are several
stories about how
that might be possible.
One route is that
we continue to do
what we've been
doing for 70 years,
slowly accumulating
better software.
I used to be an AI researcher
for nine years-- a while ago.
And so when I go to
conferences and I
meet researchers who
have been in the field
for at least 20
years and ask them,
in your subfield
that you know best,
how far have we come
in the last 20 years
as a percentage of the distance
to human level abilities,
they usually say 5% to 10%--
no noticeable acceleration.
At that rate, we're talking
two to four centuries, which
is a short time, but not in
your lifetime necessarily.
Other people say, past
progress is no indication
of future progress.
We've got a really great
theory just around the corner.
And when we do, everything
will be easy-- maybe.
I'm going to explore a
third scenario, a relatively
conservative scenario.
This is the idea, of course,
as you know, porting software.
We're going to try to
port the software that's
already in the human brain.
To do that, we
need three things.
We need lots of fast
parallel computers, which
we don't have enough of yet.
We don't have any
of these things yet,
but we're working on it.
We need to have the ability to
take particular human brains
and scan them in very fine
spatial and chemical detail.
And then we need to have models
of how each type of brain cell
works in terms of
taking input signals,
changing internal state,
and sending output signals.
If you have all of
those things, then you
can basically take
a particular scan
and make a model of
that particular brain
with your models of all the
particular brain cell types.
And if your models
are good enough,
your scan's good enough,
the entire thing should
have the same input/output
behavior, i.e.,
you can hook it up with hands,
eyes, ears, mouths, and talk
to it, talk back,
ask it to do things.
It might do them.
If you have that sort of
thing and it was cheap,
a lot changes.
Now, when might that happen?
It depends on how deep into
the brain structure we go.
The brain's cells
are very complicated.
If we have to do a lot
of that complexity,
it'll take longer before
we have computers that
are cheap enough to do that.
If not, we can do it sooner.
But still, the
forecast is roughly
in the next century or so.
That's roughly the time scale.
Now, I've been around
people-- some of them
in this room-- for
30 or more years
who like to talk
about this subject.
It's a favorite bull session
topic for college students.
When the subject comes up, the
favorite topics are usually,
is it even technically
possible to make a machine that
acts just like a real human?
If we were to do it, is it
going to be conscious or is
it just a bunch of wires?
If we made a copy of me, an
emulation of me, is it me
or is it somebody else?
Those are all
really fun subjects
that I'm going to ignore.
[LAUGHTER]
I think they're overdone.
You're welcome to take them on.
But I want to talk about
a neglected subject.
So I have written this book,
"The Age of Em-- Work, Love,
and Life When Robots Rule the
Earth"-- just out June 1--
some favorable quotes.
I decided to focus on what
would actually happen.
What would be the actual
social consequences
of having this technology?
What does the world look like?
Now, if you look up on
Amazon the keyword history,
you'll find about 20% of the
books have the keyword history.
1% have the keyword
future-- a lot more interest
in the past than the future.
Interestingly,
though, if you looked
at historical fiction and future
fiction, it's about the same.
And you might ask,
well, why don't we
study the future more
because we can do something
about it, maybe?
Past is kind of too late.
And the usual answer people
give you is, well, duh,
we can't study the future.
We can study the past.
See all these artifacts
and stuff we've got around?
We can study the past because
we have these artifacts.
No artifacts about
the future-- no study.
I think that's wrong.
So we have theory.
I'm a social scientist.
So think about three different
ways to think about the future.
One is to just take
current trends,
like increasing leisure,
decreasing religiosity,
increasing promiscuity,
whatever it
is, project those
trends forward, think
about where they lead.
Another way to do futurism
is to imagine disruptive
technologies-- self-driving
cars, blockchains--
and try to imagine the
details of those technologies.
But a third way
of doing futurism
is to take one of those
disruptive technologies
and ask, what are
the consequences?
What follows as a result?
And that tends to be neglected
because the people who
take these disrupting
technologies seriously
tend to be technologists,
physical scientists.
And I learned when I was
a undergraduate, graduate
physical scientists--
that the standard view is
those social scientists,
they're bullshit.
They don't know
anything-- doesn't exist.
So I became a Ph.D., and now
a professor of economics.
And I can tell
you it does exist.
And this book is in part trying
to show you that we know a lot,
and we can apply lots of things
we know to find out answers
to questions like this.
So this is a map of academia.
These are different major fields
connected by co-citation links.
When they cite each other
a lot, they're linked.
So academia is a
circle-- go figure.
I don't know why.
But I can tell you that
these are the fields
I'm drawing on for this book.
I have an unusually
diverse background.
So I've turned
that into a virtue.
It's usually not a
virtue in academia
to know too many fields.
But I'm going draw on
that for this book.
That allows me to take
some simple strategies,
like pick the low-hanging fruit.
I'm just going to go area by
area through a civilization
with this brain emulations and
ask, what do standard theories
predict about this?
And when I find easy
things to say, I say them.
And when it looks hard,
I go on to the next one.
I am applying theory here.
So I'm a theorist.
I'm staking our standard
theories and applying them.
I'm going to do
what theorists do
everywhere, which is we look
for our keys under the lamppost,
i.e., we make simplifying
assumptions as necessary
to get concrete results.
That's what we always
do-- welcome the theory.
So this is my last
slide where I'm
going to tell you how
I'm doing what I'm doing.
And then after this,
I'm going to start
telling you all the results that
I've learned about this world.
But just to be clear, cover
my ass-- I'm an academic,
after all-- first
of all, I'm just
trying to apply
standard consensus,
not be creative or
original, other than asking
this unusual question.
Secondly, I'm going
to focus on just
saying what this world
looks like whether I
like it or you like it.
It's not my job to
make you like it.
My job is just to
tell you what it
looks like with the path
of least resistance,
as if we did the least to
stop it-- just what it's
most likely to become.
Not that much happens to
humans during this era.
I will talk about them.
But mostly, the focus
is on the robots
because a lot happens for them.
I'm not going to tell you
about the entire history
of the universe for the
next trillion years.
My ambition, which I think
is pretty ambitious enough,
is to tell you about the next
great era after ours that's
as different from
our era as ours
is from the farming or foraging
eras that came before us.
That's plenty for me,
thank you very much.
I'm going to focus on what
happens once this world is
in its groove where people are
know roughly what to expect
and they can see their world.
You are now in the
industrial era.
The industrial era has reached
some sort of rough equilibrium.
You know kind of what
our world's like.
Early on in the
Industrial Revolution,
people didn't know
where it was going.
They were scared.
And it was a lot
harder to predict
what was happening
during a transition
than it is during
the equilibrium.
I'm going to take a standard
economist method called
supply and demand.
This is our usual first-cut
analysis of everything
because it's our best and
easiest first-cut analysis.
This is basically assuming a lot
of competitors and relatively
little regulation.
It's a world out of control.
Nobody runs it.
There's no vote taken on what
people wish would happen.
The world just
happens as a result
of many small local actions.
Finally, these
emulations-- I'm going
to make simple assumptions
about them which I think
are more reasonable in
the early era, at least.
You have a simulation.
You made a scan and
you made a model.
And you have it.
And it's mostly a black box.
There's a few tweaks
you can make to it.
But mostly, you can turn it on,
turn it off, copy it, erase it,
run it fast, run it slow.
That's about it.
And now I'm going to talk about
what does that world look like?
We have these cheap emulations.
Those are the things
you can do to them.
This is the
assumptions I'm making.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ROBIN HANSON: It starts out
being exactly the person that
was scanned.
So the soon as you
turn it on, you
have to tell it, you are
the emulation, sir or madam,
and convince it that it is
no longer the human because
a moment ago, it was
the scan of a human,
and that's where it was before.
So it then diverges
from that point
on through differing experiences
to become something different
in terms of its life.
But it starts out being
very human in terms
of its psychology and its
skills and its memory and habits
and things like that.
He says, why do I so
quickly dismiss the idea
that this could be impossible?
Well, as I said, I've heard that
discussion over and over again
for many decades.
I'm tired of it.
You can look it up.
There are many people
have talked about it.
But I thought so many people
have talked about this scenario
that it's worth thinking
about what would actually
happen rather than
endlessly go over
this philosophical underpinnings
of whether it could be possible
or not-- sort of a
technologist sort of attitude,
like let's just get on
with making the thing,
see what happens.
AUDIENCE: It sounds like
[INAUDIBLE] different.
ROBIN HANSON: I have many
personal opinions here that
about preferences that
are irrelevant to my talk.
You shouldn't care what I want.
You should care what I know.
[LAUGHTER]
And I'll tell you what I know.
So some things I can
tell you are just
true for any world
dominated by robots
because the key assumption is
that a robot can be represented
by some sort of computer file.
So computer files
can be made immortal.
You can archive them,
keep bringing them back.
So robots can, in
principle, be immortal.
Now, today houses and cars
are in principle immortal--
that is, you can keep
repairing them forever.
But you don't always.
So just because they could be
immortal doesn't mean they are.
Electronic files can
be sent electronically
across long distances.
So emulations or
other kinds of robots
can travel long distance
at the speed of light
by just sending the file
that represents them.
You care that you
don't kill nature
in part because you fear that if
you kill nature, you will die.
It's a reasonable fear.
But robots don't have that fear.
They know that if they are
made in factories out of stuff
dug up in mines, if they
accidentally kill off nature,
they keep going.
So they have less of an
impetus to save nature.
You can make copies
of computer files.
And that has enormous
implications.
So first of all, with the
supply and demand of labor--
today, you guys are
all in high demand.
You're all very valuable.
There's a big demand
for people like you,
a limited supply
in people like you.
You get high wages.
Isn't that nice?
When there are
substitutes for you
that are made in factories
with a very elastic supply
curve, which most stuff
made in factories has,
wages fall down to
a subsistence level
of the robots, which is below
subsistence level for humans.
And so even if the
economy gets much bigger,
still wages stay small-- at
subsistence level for robots.
The economy can
also grow faster.
So today, we need
basically labor and capital
to make stuff--
first approximation.
We can make stuff in factories,
actually, pretty fast.
But if you make a lot
more stuff in factories
and you have the same
number of people,
you have diminishing returns.
They're not actually
that valuable.
If you can make a
lot more people fast,
the economy can grow fast.
But today, the economy
doubles every 15 years.
And we don't double
people every 15 years.
So what are we doing?
We are making better machines.
This is the main way we grow
today-- is through innovation.
However, if you can
make substitutes
for people in a factory
and you can make them
just as fast as you can make
other stuff in factories,
the economy can grow much faster
than our economy grows today.
Standard growth economics
says it could plausibly
double every month or faster.
That's a straightforward
prediction of standard theory.
If the economy
doubles every month,
this whole era may only
last a year or two.
And during that era, if it
takes a year to get to Mars,
they will really not be
that interested in that.
The opportunity cost
will be just extreme.
So they will either figure out
ways to get around really fast,
or wait a while before
they take long, slow trips.
Most of you are probably
software engineers.
So let me tell you about
software in this new era.
Over the last few
decades, you guys
have enjoyed the experience
that your wages have
been slowly rising while the
cost of hardware you deal with
has been rapidly falling.
That has changed your
style of programming--
that as you are doing
more and more things that
are very intensive
with hardware,
because they're cheap.
However, when emulations
show up, all of a sudden,
the cost of emulation
falls dramatically.
And then the cost of
the emulation hardware
falls at the same rate of other
computer hardware, roughly.
So there's a sudden "Back
to the Future" moment
where you go back to old
styles of software engineering
that were less
hardware-intensive.
And then you stay at roughly
that era for a long time,
at least for parallel software.
For serial hardware, it's worse.
You start going
backward and backward
because serial hardware does not
improve as fast as the hardware
that emulations are made of.
Yes?
So the question is, do I see
programming languages changing
or evolving?
And my generic answer here is
I've looked opportunistically
for things I can say with some
confidence, and I say them.
And when I can't find a
thing to say, I don't say it.
And this is one of those things
I don't know what to say.
What I can tell you is if you
understand how programming
languages and tools depend
on the ratio of the cost
of hardware to the
cost of a person,
those things will have a
"Back to the Future" moment.
Other dimensions, I don't know.
And that's just for
parallel hardware.
For serial hardware or serial
tools, it gets even worse.
So this is your life.
You start, and then you end.
Isn't that nice?
[LAUGHTER]
This is a more complicated
life of an emulation.
And an emulation can
split off copies.
So at the beginning
of a work day,
emulations plausibly
will often split off
a few copies who spend a few
hours doing a short-term task,
and then end or retire.
These short-term copies
are much cheaper.
They don't have to rest
over the whole rest
evening in order to be
ready for the next work day.
So if you don't need to
remember the task being
done very well--
just want the task
done-- this is very tempting.
We'll talk more
about how tempting.
This is an opportunistic em.
They make more copies
whenever there's demand
for that particular copy.
They don't know which things
will be in more demand.
Some time, there's an expanding
demand-- sometimes, declining.
And that's their life.
This could be an em software
engineer or other sort
of designer.
You initially conceive
of a large system.
And then once you've
conceived of the subsystems,
you break in the
copies, who then
pursue the design
of the subsystems
and so on recursively
until you have
designed an entire system
with the initial vision
that you have.
So ems can implement much
larger design visions coherently
via this process of recursive
design and implementation.
For us, once you made a
person, they're very valuable.
And if you end
one, then you don't
get immediate replacement.
They're very
expensive investments.
These are very cheap--
easy come, easy go.
So we have many familiar
systems in our world,
including software, which
you experience something
like software rot, i.e.,
the experience that
is as you slowly
adapt them in more
detail to a particular
environment,
they become fragile and harder
to readapt to new environments.
This is true for cells
and species and products
today, as well as software.
It also seems to be
true of the human mind
because we start out what's
called fluid intelligence
and we end up with what's called
crystallized intelligence.
We become fragile
mentally over time--
and seems to be not
just brain degradation.
It seems to be a fundamental
feature of complex systems.
So I guess that, in fact,
emulations will experience
becoming inflexible over time.
So they have a
limited career length,
after which they must retire.
They might retire to an
indefinite retirement.
But they still will then have
to be replaced by younger
versions of themselves.
So they continually
make new copies
of the very first version and
train it in slightly new ways.
So emulations would
see around them
younger and older versions
of themselves that
have a very good idea of
what their future looks
like-- their future career,
their future spouse, et cetera,
because there are these slightly
older versions of them around,
and younger versions, as well.
So this is you, again.
You start and you end.
Now, this could be a
diagram describing you
if at the beginning
of a party, you
took a drug which meant that
you will not remember that party
the next day or ever again.
Now, some people have done this
sort of thing, they tell me.
[LAUGHTER]
Not I-- never I. But the
question I have for you
is toward the end of that
party, will you say to yourself,
I'm a whole new creature
who's about to die?
This is terrible.
How did I get myself into this?
You could think of
yourself that way.
You could think the
moment you took this drug,
you became a new
creature, you see,
because your future-- this
other person won't remember you.
But most of you probably
won't take that attitude.
But you could.
This is an emulation who splits
off a short-term copy, who
then ends after a short time.
It's the same structure.
And they could have
the same attitudes.
Either I'm a new creature, I'm
about to die, this is terrible,
I'm going to have a revolution--
run away, fight, destroy.
Or you could think, this is me.
It's the same person.
I'm another part of me that
I won't later remember.
I predict this is
the attitude they
will have-- not because it's
the correct attitude, because it
gets along in this world.
This is a very competitive
world because it's
at subsistence wage and it's
really easy to make copies.
In this very competitive
world, more productive habits
are greatly rewarded,
i.e., more copies
are made of whichever
ems can adopt
the more productive habits.
And this is one of the
more productive habits--
being willing to make these
short-term copies that
then end.
There you go.
Now, even though you don't mind
making a short-term copy that
ends, if you interact with
other people around you
and they don't know who
it is they're talking to,
whether you remember
other things
they said in the past-- that
gets difficult and awkward.
So a simple solution
is that they
tend to copy together as a
team, work together as a team,
and then end and retire
together as a team.
So now each one of them can have
predictable social relations
with others.
Today, it's hard to
meet with celebrities.
Their time is rare.
With ems, it turns out that
anybody can meet easily
with celebrities
because all they do
is spit off another copy
that meets with you.
The hard thing is to get
celebrities to remember you.
But we can use this feature
in the emulation world
to a nice advantage.
So today, if you have a leader--
say, the president-- and they
say, we must invade Iraq,
and you say, why, why must we
invade Iraq, and they
say, I can't tell you--
state secrets--
you're kind of stuck.
You don't know whether
to believe them.
For emulations, they can
do the following trick.
The president makes a
copy and you make a copy,
and both go inside a safe.
And inside the safe, they
can explain all their reasons
to you.
And then at the end,
you send out one bit.
Was I persuaded or not?
And then the entire
safe is erased.
[LAUGHTER]
And now you can become
persuaded of things
that you don't know why.
Yes, in the back?
Obviously, you have to
trust the structure here.
If you trust this structure to
be as safe as it claims to be,
then you can trust the answer.
If it's not what
it claims to be,
then, of course, you
shouldn't trust it.
But that's the generic answer
about just about anything
you might trust.
When it claims to be
something, it better
be what you think it is,
or you're in trouble.
Yes?
How many different
clans will there be?
Turns out-- I've got
slide in a minute.
But the--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ROBIN HANSON: So
all the copies that
originate from the
same original human--
let me call that a clan.
And now the question
might be, how concentrated
is the em world
in terms of clans?
So there are seven billion
potential clans, i.e., all
of the seven billion humans.
A very equal world would
have roughly the same number
of ems per human,
i.e., all the clans
are roughly the very same size.
A very unequal world would
be the entire em world
all comes from copies of one
human-- all trillion of them
are one.
So my prediction is that
roughly, most emulations
are come from the few
hundred most copied clans.
So that's a high
degree of inequality
relative to our world,
but not total inequality.
The basis for that is basically
looking at the variety of jobs
and saying, it doesn't seem
to be more than a few thousand
distinct kinds of job skills.
And I'm making a
prediction there.
So basically, a few
hundred is my best guess.
So I told you that I would
tell you about humans.
So it turns out most
of the emulations
are concentrated in a small
number of dense cities.
And so humans can have most
of the rest of the earth.
But the emulation cities
are kind of hostile to them.
So they stay away.
Humans basically have to retire.
Now, i.e., pretty soon,
very quickly, humans
lose their ability to
compete for wages, i.e.,
the wages they could earn
couldn't make them subsist.
However, humans start out
owning this entire economy.
And so if the economy
doubles every month,
their wealth
doubles every month.
So collectively, humans
are doing very well.
And they can have a very
rich, comfortable retirement.
Since this era only
lasts a year or two,
there's not that much cultural
change for the humans.
The main thing
that happens-- they
suddenly lose all their
jobs and have to retire.
And then collectively,
they get rich.
Now, whether any one human
has enough to survive
depends on how well
humans share and insure.
And my confident
prediction is since that
has varied enormously across
history, it'll vary again.
[LAUGHTER]
Some places, they'll do well.
And some places, they won't.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
ROBIN HANSON: The question
is, how do ems get paid,
and how do they
want to get paid?
Why do they want to get paid?
So this is a
subsistence economy.
We have seen subsistent
economy through history.
Actually, our era is
the unusual case, us.
Malthusian subsistence
world is basically
the world of pretty much all
animals who've ever lived
and all humans who have
ever lived in the forage
or in farmer eras.
In a subsistence
economy, most work
is producing the minimum
required to subsist.
So 1,000 years ago in a
subsistence farming village,
most work was done to create
food, clothes, shelter,
transport the things around.
That's where most of
their effort went.
This is a subsistence economy.
Emulations to subsist need
computers, energy, cooling,
structural support,
communication lines,
things like that.
So most of their work goes
to produce those things.
And because it's a
subsistence economy,
they have to work
hard most of the time
to earn enough to subsist.
So why do they work?
Because if they don't,
they don't exist,
which is pretty much
why all humans ever
worked through history.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
created those rules
for the ems [INAUDIBLE]?
ROBIN HANSON: This is not rules.
This is applying economics.
So standard economics applies
to ancient farming societies
or the future.
And so it's a fact of the
world that because there's
so much labor, the
marginal product of labor
has fallen to a very
low level, which
means wages are low
and not much higher
than subsistence, which means
they have to work to survive.
There's not a rule.
It's not a political
ruling or a decision.
It's just the fact of the world.
There's plenty of labor,
and it's hard to exist.
It's a economy of poverty, if
you like, in a certain sense,
but not necessarily slavery.
AUDIENCE: If the ems don't
work, can we turn them off?
ROBIN HANSON: 1,000 years ago,
if you did not work to farm,
you died.
There was no rule.
There was no ruling.
Nobody had to tell you
that or decide it for you.
It's just physics.
You don't have enough to
buy your basic subsistence,
you don't exist.
So it's not a rule.
AUDIENCE: So physics would
turn off the computers?
ROBIN HANSON: For
example, the computers
will sit in large racks
of computer hardware.
And you'll have to
rent space on them.
And if you can't pay your
rental fee, you'll be evicted.
So the question is, what does
the pie chart of the economy
look like?
Where is most of the
effort happening?
So first of all, one
level-- most jobs
are still going
to be office jobs.
That's the nature of a
complicated economy like ours.
So most of them are
working in offices in terms
of the jobs they're doing.
But in terms of the
industries, the industries
are mainly producing computer
hardware, cooling, energy,
structural support, real
estate, communication--
the minimum required to exist.
That's where most of
the money is going.
But of course, there's
innovation in those things.
There's marketing.
There's all sorts of things that
happen in an advanced economy
to support all those things.
So there's still a large,
complicated economy
with large, complicated
firms and layers
of middle management
and all those things.
But yes.
The question is, how do we
know economics works anywhere
besides a few miles around
this building or a few years
around our current era?
Isn't this all
just curve-fitting
in the actual world we
live in, and so it doesn't
apply to much of anything else?
No.
So first of all, I'd
say, no, economics
is a robust, general
field of knowledge that
applies not just around here.
It applies over
the entire globe.
We have decent economic models
of a great many very different
societies today.
We have economic history, which
applies standard economics
to eras quite differently
in the past thousands,
tens of thousands years ago.
Economists studied
those sorts of things.
And we have an
integrated social science
where we understand a great many
things besides the world we now
live in.
And so if social science
exists, as I said,
then it exists at a
degree of generality such
that we can start to talk about.
Now, of course, we'll
probably make some mistakes.
But if you were applying
chemistry or computer science
or other things to the future,
you'd also make some mistakes.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So if you're saying
that humans would retire
into relative
richness, then who'd
be creating the food and
items that these humans need
[INAUDIBLE]?
ROBIN HANSON: The emulations.
So humans become
the rich capitalists
of this world, at
least some of them.
And so with their
capital, they can
spend it to acquire things
they want from the emulation.
So some of the emulations
spend their time
doing whatever it is the humans
want-- sweeping their floors,
growing their food, et cetera,
because the rich capitalists
have money to spend.
The question is, when you have
a few rich capitalists and lots
of poorer people, doesn't
that mean revolution
unless something better happens?
And no, it doesn't, actually.
Historically, we have a vast
history of ancient societies.
And revolution was really
rare in ancient societies.
Revolution isn't actually that
much correlated with people
being unhappy, per se,
in terms of objective.
Often, revolutions
actually had happened
when people were getting richer
and then got more ambitious--
what they wanted.
So revolution is
certainly a possibility.
But it isn't necessarily derived
from the fact of a subsistence
economy because again, we have
a long history of thousands
of years of subsistence
farming economies
where revolutions
were quite rare.
When there was
famine, of course,
there was often a
social breakdown.
And whether you want to
call that revolution--
there was often a lot of
rioting and things like that
when there was famine.
And so that was
often a reason why
governments made sure to
save up food against famine.
But revolution is
hardly inevitable.
Nevertheless, you could
ask, why won't they revolt?
And the question
is, what can you do?
Again, and in societies
where there is a high degree
of-- there's a few rich people
against a lot of poor people,
sometimes there's a thing
you could do to revolt.
And sometimes, there just isn't.
AUDIENCE: I think another reason
not to expect a revolution--
if I was in this world, I'd
probably get myself copied,
have one copy of myself, take
all my vast amounts of capital,
and spend it enjoying
myself in the virtual world.
And so there'd be a
handful of ems like me
for whom there are
only a very few copies
and who spend all their
money on these few copies.
And then there'd be a
small number of people--
and I know I fancy
a life where there
are millions of copies of me
and I can get all this money
collectively from the clan.
And so nearly everybody
will be copying
these few people
who are basically
OK with this way
of doing things.
ROBIN HANSON: So I have some
slides that are on inequality.
But there's two
very different kinds
of inequality in this world.
Humans versus ems-- humans
are individually very rich.
So there's these definite
humans as the rich capitalists.
And so humans are vulnerable
there in many ways.
Among the ems, rich clans are
ones who have more copies.
But individually, they
don't have higher income--
so successful clan.
So in our world, we've had
often envy of rich families
within a nation.
But we don't usually envy them
for the number of descendants
they've had relative
to some ancestors.
We usually envy them for their
individual income or wealth.
And in this world,
the successful ems
don't necessarily have
higher individual income.
What they have is a larger
success of having more copies.
And that's not something
we actually usually
are envious about in our world.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In your model,
do the ems have bodies?
ROBIN HANSON: I'd say I'm
guessing roughly 20% of jobs
need a direct physical
representation to do the job--
drivers, factory managers,
miners, things like that.
For-- say again?
AUDIENCE: Farmers.
ROBIN HANSON: Farmers.
So for emulations
who are directly
dealing with the physical
world, they will need a body.
And it will need to be a body
appropriate for that job.
Now, we already know that, say,
when somebody drives a steam
shovel, they drive it
in a mental mode, where
they see that seam shovel
as part of their body.
So we know we are
capable of dealing
with a wide range of bodies as
something we're acting through.
But still, they would
have whatever bodies
are appropriate for the job.
Once these work day
is over, most likely,
they spend their leisure
time in virtual reality.
It's just much nicer.
And the people who have
desk jobs-- they're
pretty much going to be
in virtual reality, too,
during their desk jobs.
Question in the far back?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It seems like [INAUDIBLE].
ROBIN HANSON: During the farming
era from roughly 7,000 years
ago until 200 years
ago, most people
lived near subsistence
level, even when
there was lots of trade.
The Industrial
Revolution has been
able to produce wealth so
fast that it can grow faster
than the population, which is
why we have increasing wealth
or income per person today.
That's because we can
grow wealth faster,
but it's also fundamental
because we don't grow people
faster.
You can grow the
ems really fast.
So even if wealth can grow
much faster than our world,
since you can grow the ems
even faster, the wealth per em
still falls.
The income per em
still falls even
though they have a lot to trade
and they're collectively a very
rich, productive society.
The question is, are we
copying the entire brain
when we emulate, or
just a part of it
so that are we getting
emotions coming along?
And yes, the answer is
the simple assumption
at the beginning is
just a black box.
We copy it entirely.
It has all of the
features the original has.
We don't get to pick and choose.
And so yes, it has all
of the emotions and all
of the mental styles--
creativity, getting mad,
everything, falling in love.
So all of those things
are in the emulation.
They have all of those
desires and habits and styles,
which is why we can
reason about it.
It makes it a scenario of the
future that is easier to reason
about exactly because of that.
Humans retire basically.
And whether they do well
depends on how well they share.
All emulations started
out from humans.
And so they are within the
range of human mental styles,
but they are not typical humans.
So if we think of,
say, hardworking
and smart as characteristics,
the red dots are the people
and the dots up above the
line are the emulations,
i.e., they are
selected for being
the best on a lot
of characteristics,
which again, I estimate
roughly a few hundred humans--
copies of them dominate
this whole world.
That makes emulations-- the
typical emulation is as elite
compared to the typical human
as the typical Nobel Prize
winner, head of state,
billionaire, Olympic gold
medalist, that sort of thing.
They are all that good.
We know a lot of things about
how more productive people vary
in our society.
So I just use those to predict.
On average, emulations will
be smart, conscientious,
hardworking, workaholic,
get up early in the morning.
They'll be near a peak
age of productivity.
Today, for us, that's
about 40 or 50.
For them, it might be a century.
But whatever it is,
most of them are
near a peak subjective age--
probably also on average
be married, religious
because that correlates
with productivity today.
Emulations-- when they're
in virtual reality,
they never need to feel pain
or hunger or grime or disease.
Their bodies are
always beautiful.
It's very cheap to give them
luxurious surroundings compared
to just the cost of
running their brain.
So they have beautiful,
luxurious worlds.
But these are desks.
They're working
most of the time.
[LAUGHTER]
But when they have
free time, they
can have spectacular
virtual reality.
And the economy is large
enough to really develop
fantastic stories, music,
art, things like that.
Some of you when you
were kids saw the people
around you weren't like
you and you thought, maybe
I'm an alien from
some other planet
and someday I'll meet the
people from my planet,
and then I'll find
people who are like me.
This is literally true
for the emulations
because they all come
from a clan of people
very much like them who all
originated from the same human.
Probably, most work teams
won't have that many copies
from the same clan.
But each of them will be able
to consult with this clan
to give them on-the-site
advice about things
and to compare their
lives with many others
to tell them about things.
So they will have this new
unit of social organization
that will be used for
finance and politics and law.
And it's a very tempting unit
because you have more in common
with this than you might
with a identical twin.
They are that close.
The most traumatic thing I
think ever happened to humans
was the transition from
foraging to farming.
Foragers were well in tune
with their environment.
Their mental habits
and their styles
and what came
natural to them fit
well with the world
they lived in.
When farming became
possible, it required
people adopt somewhat alien
mental styles and behaviors.
They no longer foraged.
They stay in one place.
They now have war.
They now have marriage.
They now have property
and more inequality.
And this was hard to
get people to accept.
But the farming-- humans have
enough cultural plasticity
to create religions and
conformity pressures such
as we were able-- those
who were able to make
humans become farmers.
And this distinction
between the forger lifestyle
and mental style from
the farmer lifestyle
actually maps somewhat
plausibly onto a roughly liberal
conservative dimension
in our society today.
And so originally, say, foragers
were relatively liberal.
Farmers are relatively
conservative.
In the last few hundred
years as we've gotten rich,
plausibly what's
happened is the pressures
that make farmers into
farmers feel less compelling.
And we've drifted more
toward liberal or forager
mental styles or habits.
We're more horrified by slavery.
We're more into democracy, into
leisure, more into promiscuity,
more into art, travel.
These are forager styles.
And so many people
are proud of this.
And they see the future
continuing in this direction
as we get individually richer.
My prediction here, though,
is that while for the humans
this continues to be
true, for the ems,
it's not because they go back
to a subsistence income level
and a poor world
where the culture does
need to apply pressure
to get them to act
in ways that seem strange.
The farmer-like
cultural pressures,
the conservative pressures,
will have a resurgence
because they have a need for it.
This is your life.
[LAUGHTER]
You train and then you
work and then you retire--
three main phases of your life.
Emulations have
those same phases.
But it's emphasized work.
So they can have a small number
of copies who are trained,
and then make many
copies of those to work.
So they can lavish
a lot of expense
on very high-quality training.
And then when they retire, they
can retire at a slower speed.
So there's roughly a
linear relationship
between speed and cost.
So if you want an emulation
that runs twice as fast,
it'll cost you twice
as much per minute.
So it has about the same
cost per subjective minute.
This means if you're not
rich when you retire,
it's not a problem.
You just retire slow.
And now the world
speeds up around you.
And now humans and em
retirees have a common cause
in wanting the
civilization to be stable,
because otherwise, it doesn't
last-- for them, at least.
If you want a long, stable
retirement and you're slow,
you need the
civilization to last
a very long time relative to
the speed of those things.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is that keeping
a process in memory
if it's not running can
actually be pretty expensive?
ROBIN HANSON: Absolutely.
So actually, this
linear range over which
you can run twice as fast
and it costs twice as much,
the high end of that
range is set roughly
at the fastest device speeds.
But the low end of
that range is set
by roughly the ratio
of the cost of just
an archived copy versus the cost
of running a human-speed copy.
I estimate that to
be roughly a billion.
So you can probably go down
to a billion times slower
than human speed before you
run into these two costs
being about the same.
So at human speed,
the cost of running
a human versus
archiving that copy
is roughly a factor
of a billion,
which means you
can easily spin off
archive copies every few minutes
at a relatively low cost,
at least if you're putting
them in very low-cost archive
memory.
That's my rough estimate.
They can have a huge
range of motivations.
The world is just
defined by the people
who have both the ability
and the motivation such
that they do the
things the world needs.
So if motivation is
a high constraint,
then there'll be a trade
between ability and motivation.
The emulations are those who are
not only able to function well
in the emulation
world, they are ones
who have a motivation
such that they do function
in the emulation world,
i.e., they show up for work,
they do their job, they're
willing to split off
[INAUDIBLE] copies, et cetera.
They do the things
this world needs.
I already know many people who
are very capable people who
are workaholics, and I think
who would do fine in this world.
So I don't see it as a problem.
I see lots of
candidates-- people
who would be happy to try
to succeed in this world.
AUDIENCE: If we had
these 100 copies who
work very efficiently,
generate a lot of wealth,
after some time, how
do we replace them,
because if they
work so efficiently
and people just have everything
they need, why should they
work-- is should think about
getting better because there
are a lot of people in now,
real world, this current world,
which actually become
better, become the best,
just because there are
a lot of competition.
ROBIN HANSON: So
the question is--
SPEAKER: Use the mic.
ROBIN HANSON: Right.
Why do they work if
they're so productive?
If they're so
productive, don't they
make so much that they
don't need to work anymore
because they are so very good?
1,000 years ago,
subsistence human farmers
were a pinnacle of productivity
relative to the rest
of the animal world.
Nevertheless, they were still
living at a subsistence level.
So pretty much all animals
who have ever lived
have lived at a subsistence
level, even though most of them
go extinct.
So the few who
continue to remain
are at a pinnacle
of productivity
relative to the
others who go extinct.
Nevertheless, in a typical
animal world, most of them
are living at subsistence level.
And that's been true for
most of human history.
So it's quite possible
for there to be
a world of the most productive
and have them still be living
at a subsistence level because
there are so many of them
relative to the
environment resources.
So a very large population
of very productive people
can still have a
low income because
the marginal productivity is
low because there are so many.
AUDIENCE: Does this not
assume a zero sum game?
Ems could stop creating so
many copies of them such
that the few that remain
live very comfortably
in the same way that
we no longer have
to work 16-hour days?
We only work eight.
ROBIN HANSON: That was been true
through the entire farming era.
Through all 10,000 years
of the farming era,
if only people who could
get together and agree
not to have so many kids,
then a few generations later,
they could all live
more comfortably.
Right after the
Black Death, that's
exactly what did
happen in Europe.
The Black Death showed up.
Half the population died off.
And for the next
few generations,
people lived pretty
well because there
was the same amount of land
and other capital, a lot fewer
workers, wages went up.
But within a few
generations, they
did not make that coordination.
They did not prevent the
population from rising.
And so wages fell back
to subsistence level
within a century of the
Black Death in 1350.
AUDIENCE: So in this
world, how are humans
getting access to any percentage
of the wealth generated
by the ems?
ROBIN HANSON: So in our
world, we have retirees.
Retirees don't work
for the rest of us.
They're sponging
off the rest of us.
They're parasites.
We could say to ourselves,
let's go kill all the retirees
and take their stuff.
What are they doing for us?
But we don't.
We so far mostly let
retirees continue
to exist, spending their income
that they earned earlier.
And humans can hope that
that happens to them.
Humans can hope to be the
retirees of the emulation
world.
Now, there's a better chance
for that if they are integrated.
So part of the reason we
don't kill all the retirees
and take their
stuff is that they
are integrated
into our financial
and legal and political systems
such that trying to do this
would threaten the stability
of these systems we share.
Similarly, if ems share
institutions with humans,
they might be reluctant to
try to kill all the humans
and take their stuff because
that would threaten the peace
among themselves,
as a perhaps hope
that the more they would end up
having different institutions,
different things they use
between themselves than they
use with humans,
the more possibility
there would be to just
cut off the humans.
If all the retirees in our
world went off to some island,
then we could more
plausibly say,
let's just cut off that
island because they
would be in a separate world
with separate supports.
AUDIENCE: So like Monsanto--
when they release GMO seeds,
they're often
designed to be sterile
so they can't reproduce.
So you have to
buy more GMO seeds
from the agricultural factory.
Why wouldn't the
em factories make
sure the ems can't
copy themselves
and wouldn't want
to copy themselves
so you have to go
back to the factory
and pay a licensing fee
to get a new one to keep
the population down?
ROBIN HANSON: If at the
beginning of the emulation era,
the original developer
of emulation technology
was a small unitary
organization that
was able to maintain a
lock on its technology,
it might well try to play
monopolist of that technology
and prevent others from
using the technology,
and always pay that
firm a big fee to do it.
And that might happen
in the early era.
I just can't see that
lasting that long.
So in this scenario,
I assumed it
was a competitively
available technology--
it was available to
many different parties.
And so I find it hard to imagine
that even if that starts out
in that scenario of a
monopolist holding onto it,
that that could last
throughout this entire era.
But that's my guess.
AUDIENCE: Do you
see the ems choosing
to make copies of
themselves, or is it
the capitalist
that controls them
the one that chooses
how many copies are
made of each clan you said?
ROBIN HANSON: So
imagine it's this way.
You are an emulation.
You have a job.
You're doing your job.
You're doing pretty well.
And now there's a new place
somewhere else over there where
a job like yours is needed.
Somebody like you
over there is needed.
Now, I could be eager
and say, I really
want to find it, make
another copy of myself.
I'm searching out for it.
And whenever it shows up,
I try to make a bid for it,
like go to some
capitalist and say, hey,
would you fund some
capital so that I
could make a new
venture copy myself over
there because, hey, I'm
really eager to make copies?
Or you might not be so eager.
You might just be doing
your job and a capitalist
see this opportunity over there.
They say, hmm, this guy
would be good at that.
And he comes to you and
says, I got a deal for you.
How about we make
another copy for you?
And here are the terms.
This is the income
you'll get over there.
This is the capital
you accumulate.
Here are the rights
you will have.
Here is how the first copy won't
compete with you, et cetera.
There'll be many ways that
the terms of these contracts
could be proposed.
The economics-- it doesn't
matter that much who
makes the initial proposal.
The economics mostly
determines what
are the efficient contracts
that end up being offered.
And the main thing required
is that there ends up
being a job that's
available and that you're
willing to do it at
some reasonable terms.
If not, use somebody.
And the prediction
is as long as there
are some people who
are willing enough
to make copies of themselves
where, hey, it's another job,
it looks like a
life worth living,
I'm going to make
another copy of myself
with a life worth living,
I'm OK with that-- as long
as there are some people like
that, this all goes through.
And it doesn't that much matter
what their motivations are.
The main thing is that
they choose to do it.
Emulations could
go fast or slow.
So how fast any one worker
goes depends on how fast
is optimal for that job.
So those that
interact with humans
will go as slow as humans.
Those who might be in a
race, you might go fast.
Bosses will turn
out to go faster.
Leisure probably goes faster.
If you're a fast emulation,
than the world around you
is solid mountains--
very few things change
and there's only a few tunnels
that you can go in and use.
If you're a very
slow emulations,
however, the opposite is true.
Everything around you
is fast and buzzing,
and you better keep your fingers
out or they'll get bitten off.
So fast and slow
emulations, even though they
are identical in
the software eyes,
they really live in
quite different worlds.
And the emulations
interact with humans.
If they have a body, it
would probably be human size
because that's natural.
But if you run
faster, what you need
is a short or
proportionately shorter
body so that you can have a
natural reaction of the body.
There's a basic
physics relation there.
So as they get
faster and faster,
plausibly, it can go up to
a million times human speed.
They would have smaller
and smaller bodies.
At some point, that might
teleoperate them rather than
fit the brain in the body.
You might notice that they'll
clump into speed classes
rather than just being spread
uniformly across things.
Just like we clump
into cities, they
will clump into classes
of speed so that they
can interact with each other.
And this becomes
a class hierarchy
because these faster
emulations are high status
in many obvious ways.
They embody more wealth.
They win arguments.
They know things first.
Meetings happen in their place.
So high-speed is high-class.
You can also go much slower.
And most retirees
would be slower.
And there ends up being a
whole hierarchy in the sense
that these emulations
become ghost-like--
that is, like our traditional
ghosts of literature,
slow retiree emulations
are not up with things.
They're not paying attention.
There's not really very
valuable to talk to.
They're kind of
obsessed with the past.
They can't have much influence.
But if you want to
talk to one, there's
thousands, millions
of them around
available to talk
to if you so desire.
As I said, our
cities are limited
by-- they are
great in some ways.
But the major limitation
is traffic congestion.
That's why we aren't
all in one big city.
That's no longer
true for emulations
because they can interact across
the city in virtual reality
without actually
sending themselves.
They can have larger
cities that function well.
And so they would concentrate
into a small number
of dense cities.
We have [INAUDIBLE]
infrastructure.
And my last slide, which is
today in virtual reality,
you can interact with anybody
across the entire world
because the speed of light
to get a signal to them
is less than your reaction
time of a tenth of a second.
For an emulation
that's 16 times faster,
that needs to be within
1,000 kilometers.
If they're even
faster still, it needs
to be-- let's just say if
they're within-- they need
to be with 256
times faster, they
need to be within a
few tens of kilometers.
And so the faster
emulations go, the harder
it is for them to interact
with other emulations
without noticing the delay.
So that's a reason
not to go too fast.
A reason not to go
too slow, however,
is that you want your career to
last within roughly a doubling
time of the economy.
Otherwise, your
initial job skills
are no longer relevant
quickly into your career.
And that sets a upper
limit-- a limit of how slow
you might want to go.
And those two things
together give me
an estimate of roughly
1,000 times human speed
for the typical speed
of the emulation.
And I've other things
to say about inequality.
But I will since it's the
end leave you with these are
some positives and negatives.
I caution you that if your
ancestors were evaluating
your world, they would love
things and hate other things.
And perhaps whether
they liked you or not
would depend on the
first thing they heard.
You should think carefully about
a whole different civilization
you don't know much
about before you decide
if you love it or hate it.
But these are some
things to notice.
In virtual reality, again--
no pain, hunger, [INAUDIBLE],
they're not afraid of death.
Some of you may be in a city
like this area and you think,
I couldn't possibly
live in a small town
because nothing's
going on there.
They will think that
about your cities
because they all have much
bigger, more intricate
cities with a lot more going on.
On the negative, they are
working at subsistence income,
long hours.
There's more inequality
in this world.
Often, they are OK
with [INAUDIBLE]
bigger, more bureaucratic firms;
perhaps less nature and space
travel; less democracy;
more religion.
This is the age of em
as I best guess it.
Again, it's not my job to
make you like it or hate it.
My job is just to tell you as
best I can what it looks like.
SPEAKER: On your website,
"Overcoming Bias,"
you frequently to
behavioral biases
and how they affect people's
understandings of the future.
How do you control for
these in your own research?
ROBIN HANSON: One bias is a
taboo on assuming that we fail.
So my colleague Tyler Cowen
wrote a book about inequality
a few years ago
where he basically
assumed that inequality
was going to get worse.
And he said, how can
you deal with this?
And a lot of people
just didn't like
that because they said, hey, we
think inequality is a problem.
And you're assuming
we're going to fail.
And he said, yeah.
And so similarly,
here, many people
think that this is
a scenario where
we fail at some things
we would like to change.
And I'm saying, yeah.
So I think you should
just consider scenarios
where we fail at achieving
some of the ideals we have.
There's another
cognitive phenomena
called construal
level theory, which
says that we have an
abstract way of reasoning
and a concrete way of
reasoning, and they
have different features.
Our abstract reasoning is
more creative and intuitive.
Our concrete reasoning
is more detail-oriented
and based on analysis
and things like that.
We are prone to reason
abstractly about the future
because we have so few
concrete details to anchor us.
And so there's a risk
of becoming too abstract
about the future.
Our abstract mode also makes
us very principled in the sense
that in abstract mode,
we think of small number
of moral principles
should hold very
strongly with few exceptions.
And we think that
of all theories,
whereas in concrete
mode, we are more
willing to admit that
there's a lot of complexity
and to give people a pass on
various exceptions and things
like that.
And so that's also a thing
to be wary about the future
because it's so
abstract, you decide
that there are these
moral principles that
simply must be held.
Those are some examples there.
Do I believe whole
brain emulation
is the most likely path to
reach super intelligence?
And who are the biggest players?
So in terms of players,
there are three technologies
I told you about.
None of them are ready yet.
So nobody putting them
together, nor should they.
It's way too early for that.
But in the three
technologies, there
are, of course, many players
in computers, scanning,
and in brain cell modeling.
I have opinions about
the most likely paths.
But my book was primarily
not about that question.
So just to be
clear, the future's
important enough that,
say, we should be exploring
100 different scenarios.
That means we should explore a
scenario with only a 1% chance.
So I think this definitely
reaches that standard
of at least a 1% chance.
So I think we should
take each scenario that
has at least a 1%
chance and work it
out like I've worked out here.
And that's what this book about.
The book is showing
expertise in being
able to work out
a scenario, not--
I did argue a little bit
about why it's not unlikely.
But that wasn't the
focus of the book.
As I said, the other
most plausible route
to artificial
intelligence is slowly
accumulating better
software, as we've
been doing for a long time.
We have at the rate
of progress there--
it looks roughly two
to four centuries.
The rough guess
is about the rate
of progress it would take to
do brain emulation-- roughly
a century or so, which is
why this seems plausibly
the thing that
might happen first.
But those are pretty
weak inferences.
So I'm happy to say, hey,
there's a lot of possibilities.
And I'm not going to argue
very strongly for any one
calculation there.
I know some of the
players in brain
scanning because there's a Brain
Preservation Foundation that I
contributed some money to
that is trying to develop
better ways of scanning brains.
There actually are decent
scans of mouse brains
at a reasonable resolution.
We don't know if it's a
good enough resolution.
But we don't know how
far you have to go.
Mouse brain is roughly one
thousandth times smaller
than a human brain.
So in terms of scaling,
you have to go up
by a factor of a thousand still.
And my guess is brain scanning
is the first technology
to be ready.
AUDIENCE: Everything
I've heard so far,
you've been talking
about adults and how
they would work in this.
I wonder if you
scanned a young child
and let them grow up
in this environment,
if they would
rapidly out-compete
adults who are sort
of transplanted
into this environment.
And if so, would that
shorten the doubling time
and the duration
of this economy?
ROBIN HANSON: It is my guess
that, in fact, very quickly,
scanning children will be the
preference of this society.
So at the very
beginning, you would
be taking people at the current
peak of their human career
and copying them-- the best
software engineer, the best
lawyer, et cetera.
But very quickly as
this world changes,
the people who are
best in the human world
will no longer be the
best in this new world.
You'll need people who are
younger and flexible to learn
and adapt to this world,
and therefore you'll
want to pick young children.
Now, there's a substantial
complication here,
which is that the first scans
will probably be destructive.
So you would then have the
scenario of rich capitalists--
humans and ems, otherwise--
approaching families
of children who seem to
have a lot of potential
to be successful in the
emulation world saying,
could we destructively
scan your child
so that they have a
chance of becoming
a very successful emulation?
The obvious prediction is
some places will allow that,
and some won't.
And wherever it's
allowed, that will
dominate the emulation economy.
So my straightforward
prediction is
yes-- is that there are many
obstacles by which an emulation
economy will face resistance
in the preexisting economy.
But that happened in the
industrial era and the farming
transitions, as well.
There were long transitions in
part because of these obstacles
being overcome.
But by the time this economy's
doubling every month,
those obstacles will have
been overcome somewhere.
And so somewhere, they will
allow destructive scanning
of children.
And that'll happen somewhere.
That's just prediction on the
basis of wherever it happens,
it'll happen somewhere.
Wherever it happens, they'll
have a big advantage.
So that's it.
In the back?
AUDIENCE: Where's all
the energy coming from?
Where does all the energy come
from for this constant doubling
of ems?
Are they somehow extremely more
efficient than current people
are, energy-wise, or--
ROBIN HANSON: So I don't know
how fast this economy can
grow its energy budget.
But even if it's very
limited in its ability
to grow the energy
budget, it can still just
make its computers
more miniaturized
and use less energy.
Also, within a few
decades, we will
need to switch to what's
called reversible computing,
thermodynamically reversible.
And with thermodynamically
reversible computing parts,
you have a trade-off that
you can run it twice as slow
and use only half as much
energy per computation.
So as energy gets
more expensive,
they will just be pushed to move
in that regime toward slower
computational cycles.
But you can compensate
with more hardware.
So the age of em-- growing
fast and being big--
isn't very sensitive
to how cheap energy is.
Even if energy is
very expensive,
this all can still happen.
But I would guess they would
be so eager to get more energy,
they would spend a lot.
So one of the things
I can tell you
is that when you're using
reversible computing
hardware and other reversible
systems in general,
you spend roughly
half of your budget
on the hardware and half
on the energy and cooling.
So emulation cities
are roughly half
of the volume as cooling pipes--
full of ice water coming in
and steam coming out because
it's so valuable to spend more
on it because that's
real estate-wise,
you're spending half
your budget on that.
And so energy is a big
fraction of this economy, i.e.,
you'll spend roughly
half of your budget
on energy and cooling relative
to building more hardware.
So they'll spending a lot on it,
and it's therefore innovation.
And it will be very valuable.
And we do really know a lot
of futuristic-sounding ways
to increase the energy budget.
It's actually harder
to find futuristic ways
to make cooling faster.
So that's why I think
cooling is actually a bigger
limitation than energy.
The key argument for
subsistence level
is that no matter how
fast you figure out
that you could
innovate this economy,
you can just crank more
computers out of the factories
faster.
So as long as you can just
keep cranking computers out
of the factories faster
and the other resources
they need faster than
the economy can innovate,
then the wealth or
income per em falls down
to subsistence level.
That's the key argument.
So it's about the
relative speeds.
So even if
innovation's very fast,
as long as production is
even faster, production wins.
AUDIENCE: One thing
we didn't have time
for is how they interact
with each other.
So how do you
predict they interact
with each other emotionally
and family-wise, clan-wise?
ROBIN HANSON: So
the book has a lot
of detail about interactions.
If you look at the
sections, early on,
there's the basic setup.
And then there's some physics
and some other things.
But then we do
organizations and sociology
and all sort-- there's
whole big sections on that.
So I talk a lot about work
and how they organize at work.
And they will be in big
organized firms like we do.
But there'll be some difference
because they have these clan
structure.
They will have, I
predict, the usual sort
of romantic attachments and
inclinations in that direction.
The main complication
there is that there's
no longer necessarily
an equal demand
for male versus female work.
So plausibly, there's an
asymmetric ratio there
that they have to deal with.
And I talk about some of the
ways they could deal with that.
There are the ways in which--
so if you're in a team,
you're going to be copied
together as a team.
Today when you have
a team, you have
to worry if some of
your team members
are going to leave your
team, betraying your team
and going somewhere else.
But that happens, right?
Ems-- they don't have
to worry about that.
If one of your team member
leaves, a copy leaves.
The original stays
with your team.
So the teams stay
together for life.
So teams are a very
strong social bond.
There you can copy a whole team.
So if you have a
team around you,
there's probably
thousands or even
millions of other
copies of that team
out there that you can use as
statistics about your team.
So if I have a
relationship with Bob
or, say, Sue-- I'm married
to Sue-- and out there
all of a sudden
Bobs and Stu start
having fights and
getting divorced,
I know that my relationship may
be in trouble because there's
all these other copies
of my relationship
out there to use as data points.
And because these other
copies of me around me
create the-- not only can I
talk to other members of my clan
as sources of information, I
have to worry that things I do
will be taken as information
about other copies of me.
And that creates more
of an incentive for me
to behave because otherwise,
if he starts acting weird,
maybe the other ones
will act weird, too.
So there's a whole bunch
of things like that
that the book talks about.
AUDIENCE: So we
were already talking
about political structures and
about power and revolution.
I'm just curious sort of how
you use social science to think
about that sort of stuff.
ROBIN HANSON: The question
is about politics,
though there are chapters
and sections on politics.
First thing is to
say is that autocrats
relative to democracies have
some relative advantages here.
That doesn't mean
democracy disappears.
But the proportion shifts.
So autocrats here,
again-- we have
the safes that
can help you trust
a leader, an autocratic leader
via the safes I talked about.
Also, today, autocrats
have the problem
that the few people
around them--
they need strong
loyalty from them
and they have to be
afraid of betrayal
about the few
people around them.
Ems can just have
copies of themselves
around them as the leader.
Leaders can run
much faster here.
So you can have
very fast leaders.
And that allows
bosses in general
to have more advantages.
So hierarchies here are probably
shorter because the bosses can
have larger spans of control.
Those are some of the things
to say about politics here.
One em, one vote just
doesn't work here.
Perhaps speed-weighted
voting does
work, and which, of course,
gives the government
an excuse or a reason to
monitor everybody's speed all
the time-- so that
they can weight them
appropriately in the election.
AUDIENCE: It looks like you
thought through this scenario
of the future in great details.
I'm very curious about
your thinking process.
How did you get to
this point where--
I think you managed to
answer most of our question
in so many details, and
which I think is better
than most people I heard.
ROBIN HANSON: As
I indicated early,
I have spent a lifetime
learning many different fields.
Academia doesn't
usually reward that.
So I kind of squeaked
by in getting tenure.
But I started out
in engineering.
Then I moved to physics.
I did philosophy.
Then I did nine years
of computer research.
Then I went back and
did political science
and economics.
And I've read a lot.
So basically, I'm not
doing anything very special
other than having a lifetime
of learning many fields
and then just straightforwardly
applying the things I
know about all these fields.
So I would claim that if you
look at the section in my book
about the field you
know a lot about,
you will find it to be a
relatively straightforward
application of things you know.
Maybe you wouldn't have thought
of those applications, per se.
But they are straightforward.
And that's my claim here.
I'm just knowing a lot
of different fields,
and just methodically going
through each one and saying,
what does the standard
results about this field
say about this scenario?
AUDIENCE: Quick question--
followup question--
do you get a lot of feedback,
like in person from people,
or it mainly happens as a
research where you're alone
in the room?
ROBIN HANSON: This is
where I get feedback.
When I give talks,
you people talk to me.
Writing a book is
lonely, by the way,
especially if it's a weird
book that nobody ever writes
a book like about before.
So if you write a book
like somebody else's book,
then you can send them
a copy of your draft
and they'll send you copy and
tell you what they thought.
If you're writing a weird book
that's like no other book,
then you're all on your own.
So writing the book
itself is lonely.
Publishing it is
less lonely when
you get people to talk to you
about the book, like this.
So I'm enjoying this.
In order to reach the
age of em society,
we'll inevitably be experience
serious economic growing pains.
In what ways do society
have to change in order
to make the introduction of
powerful automation technology
positive for the majority
of the population?
I think subsistence
economies are OK.
That is, I think most humans
through history had OK lives.
They were lives worth living.
So most foragers in the
woods, most farmers--
subsistence farmers--
sometimes, there were famines.
Sometimes there were
invasions, and then things
didn't go so well.
But mostly, humans evolved to
exist as subsistence income
worlds.
And that's where most
humans ever did exist.
And those lives are OK.
So I think a future of
subsistence ems is an OK world.
So in that sense, it's
positive because there's
probably less war here,
there's more-- again,
no grime, disease, pain.
There's some other
nice positives here.
So I already think this
is reasonably positive.
But there's obviously always
a lot of opportunities
for making things better.
But I have to tell you that when
people talk about the future,
they seem to me overwhelmingly
tempted to evaluate and discuss
whether they like things or
not before they've even done
the very basics of analysis.
So I feel the thing
I can contribute
is to get people to pause
longer and do more analysis
before they jump
into evaluation mode
because I have no doubt they
will get to evaluation mode.
I do not feel any need
to jump in and offer
my first evaluation
so as to decide
what they should evaluate.
Evaluate on your own terms.
You figure out how you evaluate.
But first, please,
pause and think
about the actual world
you're talking about.
See it in some detail.
Learn a few things about
it before you jump in
and evaluate it.
And then once you
do some evaluation,
maybe you can think about what
you like and you don't like,
and we can think
about ways to push it
in the directions you like.
It's not so hard.
The hard thing is to get
this baselines estimate
of what the world looks like.
If you don't have the foggiest
idea what a world looks
like, you jump in to try to fix
it, that just doesn't go well.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned ems
making decisions and signing
contracts.
So would they need some sort
of secure execution environment
in order to do that so it
would prevent something
else from manipulating
their emulation
software to make them make
decisions that they wouldn't
normally make?
ROBIN HANSON: All of
human and animal history
has involved people
making decisions
in contexts where their
things they rely on
are usually, but not
always, reliable.
That includes pretty
much all of human history
making contacts and demons.
And pretty much all of
human history, people
have tried to
persuade each other
to be favorable in the ways
that are fair and unfair.
I just predict that
all continues here.
They will continue to use
mildly unreliable, but mostly
reliable, mechanisms, as we
have, with some improvements
to make whatever deal they can.
And yes, they will try
to influence and persuade
each other in licit
and illicit ways.
It just seems like an
easy prediction to me.
How could it be otherwise?
[APPLAUSE]